that's creepy this is now giving me
really creepy vibes now that I really
know what it's from
I am buff like movies I'm actually like
it
one of those annoying like pretentious
like you guys honestly I feel like if
you give me a few blockbusters like
throw jaws my way I got [ __ ] you know
love and basketball I got you anything
outside of that probably not so I feel
like Eric might take the take the W home
today but I'm gonna try really hard no
Jade I agree I think I think I'm gonna
win
I mean okay all right we got a little
furry pen this definitely has to do with
like a super girly film this feels like
an Adam Sandler movie right here
this is definitely not using Mean Girls
another pink thing all right we got two
pink things this is a pink dog leash Oh
Oh big dog leash 101 Dalmatians
[Music]
all right next clue Harvard a Harvard
Hat walking my dog with my harvard hat
and got my little pen get nothing
there's nothing going on in here right
now
there is zero happening I'm scattering
for so what this is Legally Blonde
[Music]
any Cosmo girl would have known
briefcase all right whoa I'm gonna guess
this is a very important item from the
movie the big short I know it's not it's
the big short it's not the big short
next time I need another hand taped up
parrot I have not watched a movie where
men have briefcases and murder parrots 1
over 30 turbo lakhs it's instant relief
from constipation but something tells me
that this is a prank that someone did in
a movie oh I know I know what this movie
is it is big fat liar Cobar yeah I'm
gonna go with some Magic Mike action in
here
clue number 2 where are you manly scent
of a man smells like man that's for sure
it's no this is in Matilda no I need
another clue spiders spider [ __ ] is
happening right now is this is this what
you use for like Cologne 0:04 that that
thing yeah I'm doing this and I'm
feeling something take me back to 90
just taking me back
Oh got it
okay we got some glasses intense glasses
matrix baby I ain't gotta take off your
hat for this one these glasses just too
cool they don't need a hat oh this
person is fancy only ports I don't even
say that word al Ming Mecca sports
Almanac I know what it is
okay cool hat back to the future okay
typewriter typing looks like something
I've seen on a on a on a movie poster
jeez creepy kids it's just making me
think of creepy things like writers
children I know what it is it's this
shining
witty we learned that just because you
haven't watched every movie doesn't mean
you don't know
some movies and I learned that just
because you're a pretentious little
[ __ ] and have been to Sundance it
does not mean you'll be able to guess
movies off objects I've never felt this
dumb why does buzz for you always make
me look so dumb on camera
[Music]